[Aplausos]
hace varios años estábamos haciendo un
documental sobre mujeres migrantes en
honduras república dominicana y panamá y
estábamos registrando estos rostros
anónimos de estas mujeres migrantes
una pregunta que hacíamos para empezar
las entrevistas
tanto a las mujeres migrantes como a
otras mujeres que trabajaban con el tema
de la migración femenina
yo les pedía que por favor me
escribieran con sus palabras
como eran estas mujeres migrantes
la hermana del dt que era en ese momento
la directora del centro de atención al
migrante en honduras el centro de
atención al migrante en realidad existe
en todos los países sobre todo los
nuestros verdad en centroamérica y son
muchas veces un ala apartada de los
aeropuertos donde no vemos porque está
precisamente oculta en el que se recibe
a las personas que han sido retornadas a
su país y que muchas veces más llamamos
deportadas
esta mujer cuando yo le pregunté qué me
describiera quién era estas mujeres
migrantes me dijo algo que desde ese
momento para mí significó un cambio de
percepción tanto de mi madre
de mí misma y de la relación que yo
tengo con ella ella me dijo las mujeres
migrantes
son mujeres que no migran por ellas que
emigran por todos los que están atrás de
ellas que muchas veces son sus padres
pero casi siempre son sus hijos
estas mujeres migrantes deciden emigrar
para que los que están atrás de ella
puedan estar mejor aunque ellas ya no lo
vuelvan a estar más
son mujeres valientes son mujeres santas
porque son mujeres que están dedicadas a
la vida
cuando aquella mujer me dijo estas
palabras
se me construyó un montón de conceptos y
de formas en las que yo había visto a mi
madre por muchos años mi madre fue una
mujer que emigró cuando yo tenía seis
años y no volvió a regresar al país a
vivir nunca más
según la organización internacional para
las migraciones el 50% de la población
migrante es migrante femenina
y de esa la gran mayoría de las mujeres
también
migran por tres razones fundamentales
estas son la primera y la más dolorosa
es que muchas veces están huyendo del
maltrato que están viviendo en sus
propios hogares es decir que son
víctimas de violencia en sus hogares y
huyen por eso
la segunda es porque no han tenido la
educación que les permite poder tener un
empleo digno y que con ese empleo digno
ellas puedan sostener a sus hijos en su
tierra
y la tercera razón es porque también son
mujeres que viven en un contexto en
países de alta violencia o en países de
guerra
mi madre reunía estas tres
características
el tema de la migración sobre todo en
nuestros países ha cambiado
ya sabemos que se nos reconoce como el
triángulo norte y esto significa los
países más violentos del mundo que no
están en una guerra declarada
esto hace también que el concepto del
migrante ahora salvadoreño hablando de
nuestro país pase de ser de un migrante
a una persona que busca refugio qué
significa eso que está huyendo por
salvaguardar su vida
hace unos días o meses más o menos
algunos de nosotros pudimos ver las
caravanas que pasaron ya sea porque
íbamos caminando íbamos en nuestros
vehículos o pasaron por una calle
cercana donde nos movemos
estas caravanas en realidad le dieron
una visibilización al tema de la
migración pero en realidad yo quiero
hablar más de lo que no vemos
las personas migrantes en realidad en
nuestro país diariamente salen alrededor
de 300 personas
se reciben en estas alas del aeropuerto
que no vemos
diariamente 200 personas retornadas de
eeuu y 150 personas alrededor son
recibidas en la casa del migrante por
vía terrestre que son aquellas que no
lograron llegar a estados unidos y son
retornadas a su país de guatemala o
méxico
esto ya es abrumador si nosotros
cuantificar amos estas sumas tendríamos
en realidad una caravana frente a
nosotros diariamente
pero también me gustaría hablar de no
solamente el camino que tienen que
atravesar nuestras personas migrantes no
hablo solamente de los desiertos no
hablo solamente de cruzar ríos de tener
que enfrentarse con cárteles de drogas
de tener que muchas veces caer en
víctimas de trata o explotación o
desaparecer y morir
quiero hablar de unas heridas que son
mucho más difíciles de cuantificar
porque las estadísticas muchas veces no
pueden cuantificar el dolor y ese es el
tema que realmente me tiene aquí ahora
frente a ustedes
las heridas de una mujer que emigra son
profundas
una mujer migrante usualmente piensa
tengo una necesidad grande tengo un hijo
o una hija como fue el caso de mi madre
y yo me tiré un par de ellos daños y
luego voy a regresar
estas mujeres se ven en la necesidad de
romper esas promesas porque en
definitiva no es fácil la llegada
cuando estas mujeres llegan a su destino
se dan cuenta que para sobrevivir ellas
y para sobrevivir sus hijos acá tienen
que tener doble trabajo
trabaja alrededor de 16 horas o más
no tienen a alguien y no les alcance el
dinero para que puedan además cuidar a
sus hijos y así poco a poco estos ciclos
se van a ir viendo más grandes
también estas mujeres lo que sucede como
la describía la hermana del dt es que no
solamente ven por sus hijos luego que
están fuera sino que ven por toda su
familia y entonces estas mujeres se
vuelven el sostén para los abuelos los
hermanos los hijos de los hermanos sus
propios hijos y así van sosteniendo sin
que nos demos cuenta y de manera muy
silente la economía de nuestros países
si nosotros empezamos a cuantificar
que las personas que emigran en realidad
y sabemos que nuestra economía depende
muchísimo de las remesas familiares
podríamos entonces hacer una pequeña
cuenta si decimos saber si el 50 por
ciento de estas mujeres que han migrado
mandan remesas familiares no estaría yo
exagerando en que posiblemente el país
entero en gran medida se sostenga por
esta economía de la cual nunca hablamos
qué sucede con estas mujeres que se van
pero que también sucede con estas
mujeres que se quedan
a lo largo del trabajo que yo he hecho
en temas documentales sobre todo el tema
de migración y género
me encontrado con estos perfiles una y
otra vez y sucede que la mujer que va y
se va de su país deja a sus hijos en
manos de otra mujer
las fotografías que ustedes ven ahora
para mí son muy significativas una soy
yo cuando era muy pequeña con mi madre
una relación que perdí para siempre y la
otra es con mi tía quien tuvo a bien
cree criar me y también sentirme como su
hija
es interesante como hay una sonoridad
entre las mujeres que muchas veces
tampoco hablamos en estos contextos
es interesante también identificar
que hay cosas que se pierden para
siempre
que no tienen vuelta atrás
qué cosas me refiero
a mí de pequeña recuerdo que me creaba
grandes conflictos los días de la madre
y los días del padre mi padre nos
abandonó casi que desde siempre
pero los días de la madre cuando yo
hacía esas tarjetas yo no entendía muy
bien quién tenía que entregar el des a
tarjeta de la madre
y con los años me entraba más conflicto
porque empezaba yo a sentir que ese amor
de hija madre no lo miraba como lo
miraban mis amigas del colegio o mis
compañeras
evidentemente se iba rompiendo esa
relación y se iba rompiendo ese vínculo
y es muy doloroso porque lo sienten
ambas partes lo siente el hijo que se
queda y lo siente la madre que se va
la uca hizo un estudio breve sobre las
consecuencias de la migración a nivel
emocional y decía que los niños que se
quedan
sufren y esto a través de la psicología
los mismos síndromes que sufren los
niños que tienen abandono
es el mismo vacío el mismo nivel de
inseguridad que se crea y la y la misma
incertidumbre también
esto es muy interesante porque en
realidad si nosotros pensamos en un niño
de 4 5 o 6 años como los tenía yo y de
un día para otro tu familia se
desintegra y tu madre se va y por
destinos estás entrando a la casa de
otras personas
esa niña va a crear una inseguridad de
lo que le va a venir en la vida para
siempre esto yo no lo entendí sino hace
pocos años no entendía por qué tenía
tanta inseguridad de todo entonces la
psicóloga que me atendía me decía brenda
es que esto te pasó muy pequeña cuando
estás recién creando vínculos y
fortalezas
es interesante porque a pesar de que hay
estudios todavía no se ha cuantificado
cuáles son las consecuencias de esos
dolores emocionales
yo estoy muy agradecida con la vida
porque creo que he tenido mucha suerte
no solamente de la vida que me ha tocado
vivir porque la aprecio y es mi mayor
inspiración pero también de la carrera
que elegí desde muy pequeña me di cuenta
que mi manera de expresarme era la
escritura y me aferré a ella desde muy
pequeña luego también me di cuenta que
me gustaba mucho la cinematografía me
gustaba mucho escuchar a otros y que
otros también pudieran contar sus
historias
haciendo otro documental siempre de
inmigración pero ahora curiosamente
desde la perspectiva de la infancia
entrevistamos a una niña de 6 años que
se llama tania
yo también le pregunté
y le pedí que fue amor me explicará cómo
era para ella el viaje que había hecho
su madre
tania me contó un breve cuento
ella me dijo lo siguiente bueno
mi mamá tenía un esposo pero ese esposo
era malo con ella le pegaba y la dejo
entonces vino mi madre
y consiguió otro esposo y con este
esposo
se fueron a estados unidos en un coyote
y fueron felices para siempre sin mí
recuerdo que cuando esta niña me dijo
esto de alguna manera sentí que yo era
también esa niña de 6 años
y recuerdo entonces haberme puesto a
hablar con ella y decirle a ver tania
mira
tu madre es una mujer que te quiere
mucho y en realidad no se hubiera
querido ir le duele mucho haber seguido
pero sabe que si se quedaba no iba a
poder te dar lo que puede darte ahora
que vayas al colegio que tengas lo que
necesitas y que seas lo que querrás ser
pero tu madre no está contenta sin ti no
está feliz para siempre sin ti
esta frase al decirse la a tania también
me la dije a mí misma y fue poco a poco
que fue reconstruyendo de mejor manera
esta relación que yo tengo con mi madre
como la percibo a ella como lo entiendo
a ella y como me entiendo a mí misma
como nosotros podemos identificar a
estas mujeres qué podemos hacer por
estas mujeres antes de que emigre
qué programas podemos crear para generar
una red de apoyo para que estas mujeres
puedan permanecer con sus hijos
en realidad es muy difícil determinar a
alguien que está en una situación de
vulnerabilidad tal
lo único que nos queda es tener la
posibilidad de escucharnos más
de hablar más con el que tengo al lado
posiblemente una mujer migrante o una
mujer que está en necesidad de migración
esté trabajando en nuestra casa
esté trabajando en nuestras fábricas
esté trabajando nuestra tierra
si nosotros no vamos a poder darle un
sueldo digno
una vida digna esta mujer también
terminará yéndose en algún momento de su
vida
son alrededor de 200 millones de
familias afectadas por la migración
efectivamente no sabemos qué tan hondo
han llegado estas heridas en sus
consecuencias pero no me extrañaría que
muchos de nuestros problemas sociales
sea por este desarraigo y ese vínculo
roto
estas mujeres que están sosteniendo
nuestra economía
[Música]
a costa de un gran dolor deben ser
reconocidas debemos escucharlas debemos
aprender de ellas y debemos de dejarlas
de estar en la oscuridad a mí me duele
muchísimo cuando por ejemplo un avión
aterriza con personas migrantes y tengo
que ver la fila sobretodo de estas
mujeres que regresan a su país con la
cabeza abajo
no es justo no es justo después de que
dedicaron muchos años de su vida a
sostener esta economía y nuestras
familias que estas mujeres tengan que
regresar con la cabeza agachada
estas mujeres deben ser reconocidas como
un pilar fundamental de nuestra economía
y de nuestra sociedad pero además deben
ser reconocidas con la necesidad urgente
de que menos de ellas tengan que salir
de su país
espero que así como yo he logrado tener
la oportunidad en la vida de ir poco a
poco entendiendo quién es mi madre que
quería mi madre hacer por mí quién soy
yo y cuál es mi relación con ella
entenderla poco a poco y ojalá que estas
mujeres no solamente vivan de las
alegrías prestadas
que no solo vivan de las alegrías porque
hacen que logren otras cosas por medio
de lo que ellas hacen que sean felices
por lo que los otros logran superar por
el trabajo que ellas hacen sino que
finalmente sean reconocidas como estos
pilares que realmente nos sostienen a
muchos de nosotros también tengamos un
poco más de conciencia del trabajo que
implica ser migrante
para mí es muy doloroso que estas
mujeres que usualmente salen de las
zonas rurales y que son efectivamente
las que más mucho más que los hombres
las que envían remesas familiares sus
familias luego se acomoden a recibir la
remesa familiar y dejen de ser sus
actividades porque lo que le mandan allá
afuera es mucho más de lo que ganan acá
adentro estamos siendo muy injustos con
ellas y estamos realmente defraudando
les sin que nos demos cuenta
me gustaría pensar que estas mujeres no
lo pierden todo me gustaría pensar que
algo de bonito y de paz después de esa
vida dedicada a otros les queda en el
alma agradezco muchísimo que me hayan
escuchado y agradezco mucho que podamos
de ahora en adelante escucharnos más
gracias
[Aplausos]